Starfire is now available to download in
injustice - hey everyone Greg here from
GameSpot universe it's the channel for
everything else we love other than games
be sure to click that subscribe button
right here so you can stay up to date
with all of our awesome content now
let's take a look at the new injustice 2
DLC character princess corriander aka
Starfire when Starfire is releasing it
in a fighter pack along with Red Hood
and sub-zero
created by Mark Wolfman and George Perez
Starfire made her debut in the 1980s
since then she's been a part of the Teen
Titans
The Outsiders Justice League and a few
others oh and at one point she almost
married Dick Grayson but Raven betta yep
that's me now before we get into the
comic books be sure to check out
GameSpot universe where we cover movies
TV shows comic books and so much more
her character bio and injustice too
seems to stick pretty close to her comic
origins and the comics Starfire was
conceived as an exotic alien princess
was both sexy in appearance and a fierce
warrior
so basically Red Sonja in space nether
realms character design seems to stick
pretty close to star fires comic books
with long flowing fiery red hair
completely green eyes and her revealing
bikini like armor that's what the boys
usually say back to the comics Starfire
was the younger daughter to King my and
ur her older sister commander aka black
fire was the victim of a rare childhood
disease that rendered her unable to fly
due to that one flaw commander was
deemed unworthy of ascension to the
Tamarian throne commander's princess
status was transferred to her a younger
sister corriander who had no
abnormalities and was well-liked by her
people
commander grew to despise her younger
sister setting up a sibling rivalry of
epic proportions as commander
continually sought revenge against
corriander this will conclude with a
series of events that ultimately brought
the Tamarian princess to earth where she
would soon join the Teen Titans speaking
of the Teen Titans one of the most
memorable story lines for Starfire was
her long relationship with Dick Grayson
aka Nightwing in the New Teen Titans run
now in the current injustice to
storyline Dick Grayson is dead
okay I'm sure you're wondering how did
Dick Grayson meet his untimely demise
Grayson died after Robin had a temper
tantrum he threw one of his college
dicks at his head which caused Nightwing
to fall over and snap his neck over a
rock I want none with dick Grayson's
killer moving on let's take a look at
Starfire's powers and abilities despite
her pin-up girl looks Starfire possesses
great superhuman strength she can even
go toe to toe with her Titans teammate
cyborg after I win you want to get pizza
Starfire also has the powers of agility
astral projection stamina last power
intellect and of course flight so what
you expect from Starfire when you pick
up your controller and play injustice to
the developers made it clear that
Starfire is a beginner character who has
smaller move sets compared to others and
her moves are described as being more
straightforward
she floats above the ground and can
create weapons and projectiles out of
green energy in addition to her basic
jab in spin attacks she has a few
different shaders in the game as well
one of which is a black fire shader that
changes a few of her abilities given her
a better mid-range game her super move
in the game fires a barrage of star
bolts to her opponent sending them into
space she finishes her opponent off by
unleashing all of her energy into a
supernova sending her opponent crashing
back to earth thanks everybody for
watching let us know in the comments
section if you're stoked about Starfire
in this game and if you already download
the character let us know what you think
about her gameplay and as always keep it
here to GameSpot and GameSpot universe
letter guys bye bye